sometimes i had no money sometimes i had
to kind of
bump the train or even or um
or try and connect to the wi-fi in the
underground so i could just still keep
in regular contact with emails as well
it was tough man it was
it was tough despite working hard his
entire adult life in march 2020 munya
became homeless
and working without having a home to
call his own took its toll
he never told anyone at work what he was
going through it didn't even cross my
mind too too much because i would i
would have thought that i would think i
can't manage myself i can't i can't
this guy has got so much um on like
going on in his personal life that he's
not going to be able to focus on work
he's not going to be able to commit to
it
and he was right to be concerned a
quarter of households facing
homelessness in england are in work
despite this new research revealed that
42
of employers would seek to terminate a
contract if their employee became
homeless
it's incredib incredibly stressful and
and sometimes dangerous to be to be
homeless
but to be homeless and trying to hold
down a job trying to find somewhere to
to wash maybe having to use
public toilets to wash having to be out
being able to find somewhere to prepare
food all of these things are making it
more and more difficult to do the things
you need to do to hold down your job
munya was lucky a friend's mum offered
him a place to stay until he got back on
his feet
and now he has a flat of his own
but he's not out the woods just yet
that's ending my
current job
next week and
and i've got money saved for
a couple of months but it's like there's
always that worry in the back of my head
that if i don't find anywhere else or if
i end up in the back in the same
situation would i lose the place where
i've now
caught my home as well and
there's that worry that that cycle will
just continue
crisis say high housing costs combined
with low pay and insecure work is
leading to more people becoming homeless
it's calling for employers to support
not shame staff when they experience
financial hardship
the government says tackling
homelessness remains a priority and it
continues to deliver more social housing
whilst taking action to reduce waiting
lists shimane freeman powell sky news